let's say that you are going to
psychometric ly validate the integrity
of an economic system so you'd say well
you take the smart people and and the
hard-working people and see if they do
better and if the answer is no then this
system is rotten right I mean doesn't
that make sense because you'd expect
you'd hope if a system is functioning
that faster harder working people would
be better at whatever it does and it
turns out that in our culture in the
Western culture the correlation between
conscientiousness plus IQ you have to
wait the two and long term life success
is as high as point seven which is
walloping walloping correlation given
how much chance also contributes to
success right because you can be working
hard and very smart and then you get
cancer and die and that's the end of
that like there are lots of random
events in life that interfere with your
movement forward and so there's an
errata Keable degree of chance that that
prediction is not going to overcome plus
we're not that good at measuring success
so there's error on the success end of
the measurement as well but IQ and
conscientiousness goes a long ways yes
so and that's competent